bonjour verra alors que sait-on de cet
échange entre vladimir poutine et
talibés net bonjour olivier nous n'avons
pas beaucoup d'informations concernant l
échange entre le président russe
vladimir poutine et le premier ministre
le nouveau premier ministre israélien
naftali bennett
selon le kremlin la conversation
téléphonique a eu lieu à l'initiative de
la partie israélienne
il a été question des questions elle a
été question des relations bilatérales
la lutte contre le colis 19 et une
attention particulière a été accordée à
la préservation de la vérité historique
sur la seconde guerre mondiale jean rous
d'écouté des questions d'actualité
relatives à la coopération bilatérale
dans les domaines politique commercial
économique et humanitaire ont été
examinés en particulier l'attention a
été accordée à la tâche général
consistant à préserver la vérité
historique sur les événements de la
seconde guerre mondiale a résisté aux
tentatives de réviser ses résultats de
glorifier le nazisme de nier
l'holocauste ainsi que le rôle décisif
de l'armée rouge dans la victoire
les mesures prises en russie en israël
pour lutter contre la propagation de
l'infection au coronavirus ont été
évoqués un certain nombre de thèmes de
l'ordre du jour régionales ont également
été abordés la dîmière poutine a exprimé
à naftali bennet ses voeux de réussite
au poste de premier ministre
l'intention mutuelle de développer
l'ensemble des relations
traditionnellement amicales entre la
russie israël ait exprimé les deux
hommes ayant convenu de maintenir les
contacts pour ce qui est du communiqué
du gouvernement israélien les préciser
que naftali bennett a remercié vladimir
poutine pour le rôle que joue la russie
dans le maintien de la stabilité
régionale le premier ministre s est
également exprimé sa reconnaissance
quant aux liens historiques entre les
peuples et des deux pays selon le
communiqué également
elle a été convenu d'une rencontre dans
un futur proche merci beaucoup verra
pour toutes ces précisions verhaeghe
hoffman en direct de moscou